good morning believe nation today's
message is make amends please please
forgive me over to you jared leto awake
mood in espresso TV go when I was a kid
on more than one occasion I got in the
fight with somebody in the schoolyard
and the next day they were you know
close friends so that doesn't always
happen and it's not a great way to make
a good friend but there are
opportunities for people to take some of
their mistakes and make them right and
there's nothing more powerful than
somebody who has made a mistake to
promptly admitted and to make amends
that can be an incredible thing and I
think a lot of people have probably done
that I've had regret and have changed
and have learned that what they've done
is hurt other people and come back and
said you know what hey I messed up I'm
sorry and you know i'd like to make it
right so in this clip he's talking about
his personal life but i think this
applies really well to entrepreneurs as
well because it's really important that
you make it right by the client you know
you're going to make mistakes you're
going to make errors you're going to
have mess ups that you have in your
business that are not intentional but
you still have to make it right for the
client so i stoled the story recently on
my youtube channel about i was working
with a client of mine aweber on a video
and the internet connection died on us
almost at the end of the session and i
had to make it right right I didn't want
to I didn't want them to have a negative
experience in what you guys have a
negative experience and so I booked them
in for the next day to do another
session for free on my dime and I went
to an internet cafe flew back home the
Toronto to make sure that this would not
happen and they had an amazing
experience it's also important to make
amends with the people on your team just
as early as this morning I was looking
through the videos that I'm supposed to
be recording for today and I wrote to
Christine on my video editor
Christina and I asked her to do one of
the videos that I didn't tag properly we
have a we have a system a way of how we
tag our videos that she knows what to do
next and I didn't tag and I said hey
Christina can you please get this video
out as soon as possible because I want
to look at it and she wrote back say
well you didn't tag it and she's right
it was my fault and so I accepted the
blame and let her know listen this is on
me thank you so much for doing this and
so you have to accept the blame and make
amends with your team as well I'd also
say finally that you have to empower
your team to allow them to make amends
as well to make sure that the customer
is taken care of if there's a guy on my
team name GT who handles all of our work
with the 8,000 authors write for my
website and you know we make mistakes
sometimes he might make a mistake
sometimes our system I'm making mistakes
sometimes it's not the best experience
for an author for whatever reason and
I've empowered him to let him give out
bonuses and awards and connections with
me and just different things different
ways to go above and beyond beyond just
fixing the problem like yes you fix the
problem but then also find ways to give
your customers something a little extra
because if you can do that if you can
stand out in their mind to solve the
problem quickly and then give them a
little bit more then that's an amazing
opportunity to win a client for life
because clients understand that no
business is perfect that there are going
to be mistakes and it's how you handle
that mistake and not just solving the
problem but then giving them that extra
juice to make them love you that that
will earn you potential client from
letter so the question of the day today
is I want to know how you've recently
made amends with a client leave it in
the comments below and I'm going to join
the discussion thank you guys so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events press 0
expresso keep me going